AuAu nom de toute l'équipe,
memerci d'avoir été avec nous.
DaDans quelques secondes: "Zone
écéconomie" " avec Gérald Fillin
etet Andrée-Anne St-Arnaud.
JeJe vous retrouve au Téléjournl
BoBonsoir monsieur.
CeCette histoire est relancée,
hihier, dévoilement de la 16 de
MoMonsieur Parry doit Québec, dt
MoMonsieur Bouchard. On lui
dedemande s'il est souverainist.
IlIl répond oui, ce rêve de resr
vivivant. Mais il ne va pas dans
leles modalités. Sur le fond dea
chchose, il dit, oui je crois qe
çaça reste la même chose pour le
QuQuébec, la souveraineté. Alors
onon pose la question à Monsieur
LeLegault ce matin à l'Assemblée
nanationale.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, premier
miministre du Québec
- - On est un parti nationaliste
àà l'intérieur du Canada.
NaNationaliste, ça veut dire qu?
BiBien, entre autres protéger
etet promouvoir le français.
- - Est-ce que vous avez renoncé
àà votre rêve, M. Legault?
(r(rire)
- - On a entendu un journaliste,
MiMichel David vous sentait tans
cece matin que Monsieur Legault
dadans une entrevue publiée il a
ququelques années de la présente
n'n'avait pas renoncé à ses rêv.
VoVous en êtes maintenant?
- - D'abord cette entrevue là qe
j'j'ai pris dans l'action
nanationale n'a pas vraiment
étété... AU lieu Monsieur Legaut
n'n'a pas des choses comme ça. e
nene pense pas qu'il faut se bar
llà-dessus. Pour ce qui est de e
quque pense Monsieur Legault je
pepense qu'il est du même avis e
popour Monsieur Bouchard. Comme
bebeaucoup de choses. Surtout ds
lala façon qu'il exprime ces
chchoses-là. Il dit on est un
paparti nationaliste. Mais ça ne
veveut pas dire que lui est
d'd'accord avec tout ce qu'on st
papartis et. Il sait que dans sn
paparti la moitié et séparatiste
lelentement et fédéraliste. À
momoins qu'on arrive dans un
momoment où il est objet de
prprendre position je crois qu'l
vava surfer sur cette vague. Le
fofond de la pensée je soupçonne
ququ'elle ressemble à celle dee
MoMonsieur Bouchard.
- - Bonsoir Chantal. Michel C.
AuAuger, ça réponse n'est pas
ététonnante. C'est intéressant,
d'd'abord sur sa réponse Michel.
- - Il ne pouvait pas zéro chos,
lele jour où il s'est dit
sosouverainiste la coalition vit
dede tomber. Je ne suis pas
cacapable de sonder le coeur de
MoMonsieur Legault mais il a
chchoisi d'aller, de quitter le
PaParti québécois de fonder une
papartie parce qu'il voulait ête
popouvoir. C'est je pense une
coconsidération qui est plus
imimportant pour lui que la
sosouveraineté. D'autant que, la
sosouveraineté ne sortira jamais
dudu paysage politique québécoi.
LeLe Parti québécois pourra peu-
êêtre avoir des problèmes mais a
sosouveraineté ne fournira pas.l
n'n'y a pas d'acceptabilité
sosociale pour sa ces temps-ci.
PaPas de demande. On ne s'en ira
papas faire un référendum parce
quque Ottawa dit non à la
réréunification familiale. Il ya
ququelque chose qui manque étant
quque ce quelque chose à me
mamanquer, je ne pense pas que
MoMonsieur Legault va sortir de
soson mutisme.
- - Il joue l'équilibriste là-
dedessus. A-t-il vraiment besoi,
sisi tant est qu'il croit que
c'c'est la meilleure solution pr
lele Québec, et de permanents
chchangent.
- - La raison pour laquelle la
kakayak ratisse large c'est
jujustement parce qu'il est
ininstallé sur cette clôture la.
MiMichel parle de feeling. Parfs
unune ligne fine c'est une corde
raraide. Il faut faire attentioà
seses pas. Cela dit, Monsieur le
gogouvernement des états d'âme
dadans ce sens-là, ils en seront
cocompensés appellent l'Parti
lilibéral et le Parti québécois.
CeCe seraiait comme les sortir u
rerespirateur artificiel. Parce
ququ'on retombe dans le débat ou
lala question de l'urne, pas
bebeaucoup d'électeur CS compred
unune chance qu'il y ait une aue
réréférendum sur la souverainet.
VoVous connaissez les résultats,
ceces deux parties-là ont des
chchiffres qui en témoignent.
- - Si je peux me permettre, je
pepense que la question ne se pe
papas. Elle est largement
ththéorique. Ce que les gens se
dedemandent s'il y avait une
sisituation qui reproduisait un
clclimat du genre de celui de
l'l'après lac Meech, et qu'il y
avavait une ouverture, est-ce qe
MoMonsieur Legault profiterait e
l'l'ouverture au s'il ferait que
MoMonsieur Bourassa est
ororganiserait pour que la fenêe
feferme? C'est ça la vraie
ququestion. Pour le moment
MoMonsieur Legault a aucune e rn
dede chercher les problèmes.
- - En passant les accords de
MeMeech et la suite. Ce n'était
papas parce qu'on a perdu la
chchance de mettre dans la
coconstitution les portes Québec
enen immigration. C'était sur la
rereconnaissance du caractère
fofondamental du Québec comme ds
leles autres Canadiens. Qui ne
veveulent pas accepter ce qu'ele
QuQuébec la différence québécoi.
TrTrès très franchement, si ça
avavait été juste on a échoué àa
tatable constitutionnelle à mete
dadans la concession d'effort en
adadmiration je ne crois pas qun
auaurait eu référendum à 95.
- - C'était plus fondamental.
D'D'ailleurs Monsieur Bouchard
seserait peut-être resté avec
MoMonsieur Mulroney ainsi Meech
avavait passé. Michel David toue
àà cette théorie quand même qui
cicircule, ce n'est pas nouveau.
OnOn dit si jamais il arrive un
momoment où il y a une colère
cocollective, chez les québécoi,
vava-t-il lui traverser le
RuRubicon. C'est ça la question.
PoPour certains c'est un soit
pependant cette graine.
- - La question c'est est-ce que
lala partie va le suivre. Madame
GuGuilbaults est ouvertement
féfédéraliste. Il y en a plusies
dadans les ministres importants.
- - Dubé, février bonne. Sonia
lalabel.
- - Il ne peut pas aller la
scsceller tout seul de sa gagne.
SoSon parti va cesser d'existeri
lele fait ça il ne sait très bi.
IlIl va cesser d'être premier
QuQuébec. Je pense qu'il est veu
êêtre mise Québec.
- - Je veux juste rappeler Michl
auau moment où l'accord de la tp
ininsights a échoué il y avait s
ninièces dans le cabinet Bourasa
ququ'on ne soupçonnait pas l'ome
d'd'un sentiment souverainiste i
ététait prêt à partir en guerre.
- - Ce qui est Chantal souligne,
c'c'est que l'échec de Meech
c'c'était quand même retentissa.
C'C'était beaucoup de pouvoir
poposer le Québec avait eu ses
popouvoirs là on serait sur une
plplanète. Ce que souligne Chanl
c'c'est que ces conditions ne st
papas réunies. Ces 96 d'un côté,
unun rejet par la cour suprême,
nonotre rejet sur une autre loi,
esest-ce que ce serait suffisan?
- - C'est tout ça...
- - on ne le sait pas mais on st
papar exemple que le Parti
ququébécois a vraiment voulu
esessayer ça. Je demeure convaiu
quque la charte des valeurs, le
gogouvernement de Madame Marois
n'n'a pas demandé d'avis juridie
auau ministre de la justice. Il
vovoulait se faire dire non para
cocour suprême en espérant qu'ee
a a le bouillonnement reviendra.
OnOn ne sait pas si ce serait vi
vevenu.
- - Je vais faire entendre, cele
ilil y a des députés, ça va vous
fafaire passer un film.
MAMATHIEU LACOMBE,
miministre de la Famille, Québec
- - Oui, il faut mettre notre
popoing sur la table, réclamer
cece qu'on doit réclamer,
pupuis on peut très bien le faie
àà l'intérieur du Canada.
PaPar contre, il ne faut pas
sese mettre à pratiquer
unun nationalisme gêné ou
unun nationalisme timide parce
ququ'on n'en fera pas, de gains.
IlIl faut s'assumer, je pense
ququ'on peut très bien le faire
àà l'intérieur du Canada.
SYSYLVAIN LÉVESQUE, député, CAQ
- - On fait partie du Canada
ananglais et du Canada français
enensemble. Et notre objectif,
c'c'est de faire avancer
lele Québec. Pour l'instant,
onon fait partie du Canada, il y
a a pas d'enjeu de se séparer.
NoNous sommes un parti
nanationaliste.
LULUCIE LECOURS, ministre délége
àà l'Économie, Québec
- - Moi, j'aime bien le Canada,
onon est au Québec, on va faire
rerespecter le Québec, mais dans
unun Canada. C'est un beau pays,
lele Canada, j'adore le Canada!
JeJe voyage au Canada.
- - Yvon Deschamps qui a dit un
QuQuébec fort dans un Canada un.
C'C'est de l'équilibriste parce
quque la CAQ ratisse tellement
lalarge, forcément il faut qu'ee
raratisse des deux côtés.
- - Oui, si Monsieur Legault est
sésérieux et qu'il dit que la
sésécurité du Québec est en jeu,
ilil devra devoir tirer les
coconclusions s'il n'y a aucune
coconclusion qui est faite. Où l
s's'écrase complètemement où ilt
foforcé de fonctionnement. Sinon
cece qu'il raconte de la bouille
popour les chats.
- - On est au point où Monsieur
LeLegault pour u demande de
rarabattre le pouvoir sur la
réréunification familiale dit qe
çaça nous aviation. Que c'est
paparce qu'on est proche d'un
élélection. Le déclin du franças
nene serait par Beyer. Est-ce qe
l'l'urgence est électorale ou si
elelle est réelle? Je vois le
cacalendrier et je pense qu'elle
esest très électorale.
- - Ce qui Michel David disséqut
ilil pose la question mais faite
dedevant un nom? Redevenez-vous
sosouverainiste?
- - Il fait: commeme Jean Chrétn
didisait quand on dépenserait ds
unun coin Sur la peinture. Je ne
pepense pas que c'était le but e
FrFrançois Legault de nous faire
asassister à tout ça. Ce n'était
papas ça le plan. Parce que les
seseuls qui ont les problèmes
c'c'est les membres de son Consl
dedes ministres. Toute une
ststratégie, on va arriver viteà
unun oui avec des stratégies coe
çaça.
- - Je les disais, tout ça est
paparti, les questions Monsieur
LeLegault oui du débat sur la
lalangue, mais hier Monsieur
BoBouchard qui a dit moi j'ai mn
fofondamentalement je crois
enencore. Mais il y a un gros
mamais. Le PQ ça ne va pas biene
vovous dis ça parce que je vous
prprésente un extrait de notre e
quque je vais présenter demain.
UnUne longue entrevue avec
MoMonsieur Bouchard. Il préside
leles commémorations centième
ananniversaire de René Lévesque
totout au long de l'année.
LULUCIEN BOUCHARD, ancien premir
miministre du Québec
- - L'idée, le projet, c'est un
rrêve. C'est également, je pens,
unune nécessité politique, quand
onon garde l'histoire du Québec,
onon ne peut pasas se laisser
dédépouillé comme on le fait
prprésentement. On est acculé ds
lele coin, la langue française
memenacée. Non, il faut garder
l'l'idée. Il faut garder de la
dédétermination. Mais comment?
CÇa, on le sait pas. Quelle fore
çaça va prendre ce projet-là?
CÇa va se transformer comment?
PePeut-être pas un projet
sosouverainiste, séparatiste,
cocomme on dit, mais c'est certn
ququ'il y a quelque chose qui ne
momourra pas et qui va s'exprimr
d'd'une façon ou d'une autre das
lala vie politique québécoise.
DoDonc, moi, je ne suis pas
dédésespéré à l'idée que le Pari
ququébécois ne va pas bien.
CÇa ne me désepère pas.
- - Même s'il ne serait plus là
popour vous.
- - Entre nous, il mérite ne
mémérite pas de très bien aller
nonon plus. Ce n'est pas fort,
vovous savez, c'est du bon mond,
ilil y en a des gens pour qui ji
bebeaucoup de respect, puis ils
onont du mérite. Mais disons que
ilil y a quelque chose qui ne
clclique pas dans le débat
popolitique.
- - Il y a quelque chose comme n
susupplice. On a mal pour ces
mimilitants qui restent là.
- - On peut imaginer que, peut-n
imimaginer que un parti en 2022,
enen octobre, va faire une
cacampagne électorale où il va
prpromettre de faire un référenm
s's'il est élu?
- - Pour vous, c'est de la foli?
- - Pas de la folie, mais c'est
unun manque de... C'est un défat
quque René Lévesque n'avait pas;
c'c'est un manque de réalisme.
- - Un manque de réalisme de
prpromettre référendum sur la
sosouveraineté de la part Parti
ququébécois. Monsieur Bouchard i
didit qu'on ne peut pas éteindre
lele rêve. Vous l'avez dit toutà
l'l'heure, cette idée-là, persoe
ququi est sérieux qui comprend e
dédébat politique prétend que ça
vava mourir. Actuellement,
prproposer aux Québécois
réréférendum, le PQ. Ne mérite s
d'd'aller bien. Tour de table.
- - Monsieur Bouchard a toujours
pepensé ça du PQ je pense. Ça na
jajamais vraiment appliqué entre
MoMonsieur Bouchard et le PQ.
L'L'histoire de son règne ça été
l'l'essor d'une chicane
inintérieure. Monsieur Bouchard
didit tout ce qu'il pensait ou
papas. Je crois qu'il a raison.
J'J'ai peur que les souverainise
dodoive se trouver un autre
vévéhicule après la prochaine
élélection. Que la souveraineté
dedemeure une idée vivante c'est
clclair. Je pense même qu'un
gogouvernement comme celui de
MoMonsieur Legault a tout intért
àà ce que cette idée la traîne
dadans le paysage. S'il n'y a ps
auaucun malaise qui est ressentà
l'l'extérieur du Québec, pourqui
onon se préoccuperait de ses
ététernels chialent.
- - Le PQ vit à cause de son aie
raradicale qui le force à mettre
dadans son programme à chaque
élélection on va faire un
réréférendum rappelé tout de sue
apaprès. Ça les Québécois ne
veveulent pas en entendre parle.
SeSeulement l'aile radicale du Q
crcroissant. C'est ça qui va les
coconduire peut-être à la
didispersision. Le manque de
réréalisme, c'est réel. Si on vt
quque ce partiti là que le mouvt
exexiste encore, soyons clairs l
y y a un autre article cette
sosouverainiste, Québec solidai.
CeCette idée n'est pas en traine
momourir. Mais si on veut que ça
dedevienne une force politique
cacapable de gagner un référend,
ilil va falloir faire autre choe
quque de dire: on va faire un
réréférendum tout de suite éproé
ququ'on aiderait. Ce n'est pas
cocomme ça que ça marche.
- - Concentrer sur toute la même
chchose. À part le programme
acactuel du Parti québécois, fae
unun troisième référendum dans s
ququatre prochaines années ça ft
dede l'irresponsabilité totale.
C'C'est tué l'option. Trois foi.
LeLe nom serait probablement pls
reretentissant que la dernière
fofois. Mais la France qui va
cocoller, c'est quand Lucien
BoBouchard, comme il a été premr
miministre il a été réélu
mamajoritaire ce qui n'est pas
ararrivé à personne après lui. l
a a dit que le Parti québécois e
méméritait pas de bien allait. l
a a encore du tirant d'eau.
MoMonsieur Bouchard le message
c'c'est dire que si on veut faie
çaça ce ne sera pas avec le Pari
ququébécois.
- - Je vous amène mon dernier
exextrait. Paul St-Pierre
PlPlamondon à qui on a demandé,
d'd'abord est-ce que vous croyez
quque Monsieur Legault et
sosouverainiste, la même
didiscussion que l'on vient
d'd'avoir. Vous allez voir un
momoment quand même étonnant. Il
esest abattu.
IlIl ne comprend pas pourquoi
MoMonsieur Legault n'enfourchait
papas le cheval de la
sosouveraineté.
- - Je sais pas...
(s(silence)
A À force de répéter
auaux Québécois qu'ils ne sont s
bobons, qu'ils ne sont pas
cacapables, à force d'être dans
lele pessimisme, à un moment
dodonné, oui, ça l'a un impact.
PuPuis c'est ça que je demande
àà François Legault d'arrêter
dede faire, d'arrêter de dire
auaux gens qu'ils ne sont pas
bobons. On est capable d'être
unun pays, puis on a pas le chox
sisi on veut une pérénité
lilinguistique et culturelle.
- - Il y avait beaucoup d'émotin
àà Québec aujourd'hui. À vous
alaller me dire, vous avez connu
çaça. Centrale il était comme ce
n'n'est pas tout ça.
- - Légèrement désarçonné. Il et
mimieux de se préparer aux débas
dedes chefs parce que ça va être
enencore plus rodéo que ce point
dede presse-là. Il y a beaucoupe
chchoses que les gens peuvent
MoMonsieur Legault mais
l'l'impression que les gens dist
ququ'ils ne sont pas bons pas ts
papartagés.
- - Un des problèmes du PQ c'est
quque quelqu'un comme Pierre Sat
PaPaul Plamondon soit chef. Il
n'n'est pas dans la même ligne e
leles autres. Le PQ n'est plus
prpropriétaire de cette idée-là.
IlIl n'est plus le seul véhicul.
LeLes gens envisagent facilement
ququ'il y ait un autre véhicule
quque le PQ le jour où ils
vovoudront s'en servir. Le Parti
ququébécois est vraiment dans ue
drdrôle de situation. C'est le
momoins qu'on puisse dire.
- - D'abord, Monsieur St-Pierre
PlPlamondon n'a pas assisté au
cocongrès de la CAQ la fin de
sesemaine dernière parce que
MoMonsieur Legault n'a pas arrêé
dede dire comme quoi on était bs
etet qu'on devait être fié de ce
ququ'on fait. Je comprends son
dédésarroi, il semble direct das
lele mur. On le sait. On a eu sn
aiair, du chèvrefeuille qui voit
lele voiturin relevé. Tous les
cacandidats, il n'y avait persoe
ququi pensait qu'il fallait se
prprécipiter dans un référendum.
IlIls se sont rendus compte que
c'c'est ça que les militants
vovoulaient entendre. Il savait
bibien qu'il ne peut pas gagner
unune élection là-dessus mais pr
êêtre chef il fallait passer par
llà. Maintenant ils sont pris
avavec cette stratégie laquée
susuicidaire de toute évidence.
MoMonsieur St-Pierre Plamondon a
êêtre obligé de vivre avec ça
jujusqu'à la fin. Ne peut plus
chchanger d'idée.
- - Très bien, simplement pour
didire aux gens que les cartes e
memembres pour le parti
coconservateur c'est demain
miminuit. Certains me disaient
ququ'il y a 500 000 membres.
CeCertains en ont vendu beaucou?
- - 500 ans, moi aussi j'ai
enentendu ça. Ça frappe
l'l'imagination. Certains vont
didire qu'ils en ont vendu
bebeaucoup. C'est probablement
vrvrai, Pierre Poilièvre. Il fat
sasavoir où on a vendu les carps
auau Québec ça prend 7800 membrs
etet on bat complètement la
SaSaskatchewan. À cause de
rérésultats pondérés. On ne le
fefera pas qui a vendu quoi. La
dedernière fois 100 000 ont pas
vovoté.
- - Très bien, on va en reparle.